welcome to the man of recaps this is
ozark season four part one it starts
right off with a weird scene where the
bird family is moving back to chicago
seeming to be relatively happy but
unfortunately oh they get into a big car
crash is this a flash forward to the
future is it a dream or is it a metaphor
that every time things seem to be going
well something else happens to muck it
all up now in the real present remember
marty and wendy bird are down in mexico
at cartel leader omar navarro's son's
baptism party first they have to clean
bits of hell and pierce out of their
hair reminding them how dangerous this
job is but they seem safe for now in
fact they're guests of honor it was
their plan to get the fbi to attack the
lagunas cartel and win the war for
navarro now we meet navarro's nephew
javi who's a real charismatic guy went
to business school in the states but
navarro's like yeah javi's definitely
planning to kill me and take over so i'm
gonna retire and he gives the birds yet
another impossible task he wants
immunity in the united states and per
usual their lives are on the line
because if they fail hobby will probably
kill them all so marty bird tries to
pitch the idea to his fbi contact agent
maya miller who just had her baby in is
on maternity leave while wendy bird
continues to work the politics angle
with jim rattlesdorf behind the scenes
political wizard remember he was charles
wilkes lawyer slash right-hand man but
now wendy bird is taken over as the
behind-the-scenes political queen of the
ozarks and she wants to rise even higher
to influence all politics in the whole
midwest the big problem though is hobby
cannot find out about his uncle's secret
retirement plan and he has a habit of
dropping in unannounced now we don't get
any bird family breakfast this season
who's got time for a sit-down spread but
we do check in on the kids at bird
family dinners charlotte is causing no
problems these days she's fully on board
with working for her parents and helping
out the family it's jonah's turn to be
angry now he is really mad at his mom
for ordering the death of her brother
his beloved uncle ben in fact he brings
ben's ashes to ruth who loved him and
didn't kill him and she puts them in a
funny goat cookie jar remember at the
end of last season ruthling moore quit
working for the birds and joined her
cousin wyatt over working for darlene
snell in her heroine farm ruth buys the
lazio motel to launder money through but
laundering money wasn't really her
specialty but jonah birds a young money
laundering savant he joins her and these
two become friends wendy does not
approve and spends all season scolding
him so eventually he moves out gets a
room at the lazio and is laundering
full-time now one day when javi was in
town he killed sheriff nix who was
bought by darlene snell and without his
protection frank cosgrove of the kansas
city mob backs out of their distribution
deal so now darlene has a ton of heroin
and no way to sell it ruth has a great
idea she knows some celebrity chef from
when he played in the poker tournament
at the casino and she pitches him to be
the influencer for their organic
home-grown farm-to-table heroin
unfortunately he likes the product too
much almost od's one day decides to
rethink his life choices meanwhile wendy
bird becoming a political influencer and
the main way to do that is with a
buttload of corporate money she
approaches claire shaw the new ceo of a
mega pharmaceutical company one of our
highest costs is buying the legal
medical morphine to make their various
drugs and the bird's pitcher hey what if
you bought the same product at half the
cost from the mexican cartel so the
birds just facilitated an industrial
sized drug deal between the cartel and a
mega corporation and of course they get
their cut which lets wendy by
politicians and they're all real dirty
in case it comes up she finds out this
guy's got new voting machines that can
actually fake votes now the public face
of this deal is the bird family
foundation building new mental health
and rehab centers but to make it more
real when he talks about how it's
personal cause her bipolar brother ben
is missing and unfortunately this brings
some unwanted detention on the subject
and speaking of unwanted attention
there's a new private investigator in
town mel saddam who's looking for helen
pierce because of her divorce he is
relentless showing up all the time
because he knows the birds know
something and he's like look i don't
care if you did anything illegal i just
need helen's signature for the divorce
papers or else her body eventually he
overhears the bird kids talking pretty
explicitly about the cartel so he's
putting the pieces together one day
marty over here is hobby talking about
an arms deal and he's like yo navarro
this is exactly the kind of thing you've
got to give up to make the fbi on your
side but now javi knows there's a mole
so he backs out of the pharmaceutical
deal until they find him now they
desperately need some replacement heroin
so marty goes to his old friend ruth and
it was mostly wendy she was mad at she
still kind of likes marty so now ruth
langmore is closing a 100 million dollar
deal with a mega corporation but
unfortunately darlene had just sold all
their heroin she cuts out his father and
goes straight to frank jr of the casey
mob like hey sorry i shot your dick off
last season but let's make some money
together so now ruth and marty gotta pay
extra to buy it right back during this
deal frank jr gives ruth a real
heartfelt apology for beating her up and
ruth's like hey thanks man you know what
we can be friends now but ruth and
darlene have a big falling out about
ruth making deals behind her back for
this and other issues darling goes to
yell at wendy bird but wendy bird yells
right back she's not afraid of her
anymore and in fact darlene starts
having a heart attack and wendy bird has
her walter white moment as she considers
not calling an ambulance and just
watching her die in her driveway in the
end though wendy does savor it gives her
something else to talk to about
meanwhile navarro's deal with the fbi is
moving along until one day javi plants a
bomb in one of the trucks he killed a
couple agents so now the only way the
deal can move forward is if omar gives
up his nephew so omar tells hobby he's
retiring congrats kid you're the new
boss but now he's making a deal with the
fbi to give javi and the whole cartel up
but at the meeting the fbi changes the
deal on him it's been great having the
cartel leader secretly working for them
and if they take down the whole cartel a
new one they don't have access to will
just take its place they want navarro to
keep running the cartel for another five
years giving up shipments here and there
basically attacks then after that he can
retire with immunity in america as part
of this deal the fbi would take over as
navarro's american contact including all
the money laundering and the birds get
immunity too they would finally be free
and clear they've been making plans to
move back to chicago finally get out of
the ozarks but agent maya miller does
not approve of this deal she thinks they
should be arresting drug lords not
giving them a retirement plan so she
tips off local law enforcement and omar
navarro is arrested this messes
everything up it's a metaphorical car
crash naturally javi assumes it was the
birds who betrayed his uncle and once
again marty's on his knees talking out
of his ass to save his life when he
talks to omar like hey new plan convince
hobby not to kill marty and to take your
deal and the fbi will let you go and the
new deal goes through hobby spends 10
years as cartel leader given up some
stuff to the fbi then gets to retire
with immunity but as for omar this
part's kind of confusing because it's
not stated directly but it seems like
wendy lied to him about his release
being part of the deal and he's really
disappointed in wendy because over the
last two seasons they've like kind of
become friends but she's like sorry man
it's just the way it had to go and omar
navarro i think is staying in jail
meanwhile frank senior's mad at darlene
for going behind his back to make a deal
with his son but he makes a mistake of
disrespecting darlene snell in her own
house which oh gets you shotgunned now
this kind of scares wyatt he's like yo
ruth i think i'm gonna dump darlene then
you mean three can leave town and start
a new life but if darlene's single
they're gonna take baby zeke away so
instead of dumping her he proposes and
oh now come on but just then javi finds
out that shaw pharmaceuticals cut him
out of the deal by buying from darlene
so javi crushes their wedding party and
with zero hesitation kills darlene and
without even knowing who he is he shoots
wyatt too no
and when ruth langmore finds out her
cousin's dead she goes into defcon 5.
although actually defcom1 is the worst
one but ruth doesn't care she's in full
meltdown mode doesn't care if javi's a
cartel boss working for the fbi she's
gonna kill him and that's where ozark
season 4 part 1 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member